[Music]
Brad Pitt arrives in Italy where his
ex-wife Angelina Jolie is with their
kids on vacation I feel like my world
expands as their World Experience yeah I
learned so much from them and yeah I'm I
love this stage that's the actor at the
airport in Rome on Monday sporting a
brown T-shirt cream colored bucket hat
and a coral face mask and it seems
Brad's got plans to play some tunes
while he's abroad because he's also
carrying a guitar anyone else getting
Johnny suede Vibes suits
[Music]
the Oscar winner stop in Italy comes
ahead of his and Angelina's twins Vivian
and knox's 14th birthday while they
haven't been spotted together the promo
tour is for his upcoming film bullet
train it isn't set to kick off
internationally until later this month
so chances are Brad's in Italy for some
family time I'm pretty grateful for that
ahead of his arrival Angelina and the
former couple's 16 year old daughter
Shiloh went to Mona Skin's concert over
the weekend check out the two enjoying
the show from the audience both rocking
casual black ensembles Shiloh looking
more and more like her mom each day when
your children are your best friends it's
kind of a it's a nice life now we're
finding a common theme here on this trip
Brad with his guitar and Shiloh and
Angie at the concert clearly this is a
family that loves music Take This Moment
from last month for example when Shiloh
broke the internet showing off her
impressive dance moves it's about
it imma need a Sentimental Man a woman
to pump me up feeling fussy walking in
my Valencia she's trying to bring out
the fabulous choreographer Hamilton
Evans shared a few videos of Shiloh
showing off her slick skills
[Music]
yeah safe to say Talent runs in the
family and Dan seems to be Shiloh's
Forte it's music that's been a source of
healing for Brad last month the actor
revealed to GQ that he spent years with
low-grade depression explaining quote I
always felt very alone in my life and
it's really not till recently that I
have had a greater Embrace of my friends
and family that's life isn't it you've
got challenges and you got some uphills
to face and Brad that he says he's found
comfort in things like music music fills
me with so much joy I think Joy has been
a newer Discovery later in life I was
always moving with the current drifting
in a way and on to the next and Brad
says it's not until he came to terms
with his depression that he's been able
to catch those moments of joy
[Music]